rhondella Mozena a dictionary might
define sedan as a four-seater a
four-door car or simply as a car big
enough for four people in their luggage
sportiness is not obligatory then Portia
burst onto the scene in 2009 with the
Panamera since then sedans can be truly
sporty or the other way around sports
cars can now have four doors the new
second-generation Panamera claims to be
even better both designers and engineers
have been busy making plenty of changes
and improvements
the air inlets have grown and are more
pointy and at the back the rear lights
have changed they are narrower and
three-dimensional they are like the ones
on the makan and 911 in addition a
string of LEDs linked them
in infancy inside it is like an iPad
sports car with loads and displace one
each on the left and right of the rev
counter which is thank God still analog
a big 12 inch display for the Sat Nav
and entertainment system and touchpad
areas around the automatic selector
lever so you can stroke your panamera oh
my let me since Titan but there are some
features that are not so obvious and the
engine and suspension Porsche invited a
group of motoring journalists to a
briefing at the Liao's it sling
racetrack there is a brand new
twin-turbo v8 with a new kind of iron
coating on the cylinder linings
and the new Panamera is the first car to
sport Porsches new eight gear dual
clutch transmission it promises lower
fuel consumption smoother gear changes
and even better performance
maneuverability is enhanced through the
rear axle steering borrowed from the 911
it is an optional extra dough fit like
Mateus Lieber who is in charge of
braking systems at Porsche says rear
axle steering improves cornering and
makes it easier to park with less
tugging on the steering wheel at high
speed the system aligns the rear wheels
with the front wheels which enhances
stability and agility from thought
second on what's ahead now we head out
onto the racetrack here developer Armin
Kripke demonstrates what's new about the
suspension
somebody do I come on over there is a
three chamber air spring with two air
volumes that can be shut off combined
with monotube shock absorbers the air
Springs make it possible to shut down
chambers to fit the respective stretch
and driving situation that increases the
stiffness of the springs there by
dynamically reducing the roll angle
driving straight ahead as we are here
the vehicle is very comfortable and when
you steer into a curve the chambers are
shut down the spring stiffen up and the
roll angle is reduced all this means a
suspension with the best possible
combination of comfort and sportiness as
usual various driving modes can be
selected and they also influence the new
suspension yet so now we're in Sport+
armand koepka demonstrates the sporty is
setting for the suspension and all-wheel
drive the sport exhaust has opened up
and produces a bit more sound the roll
motion and the curve is less than before
to the tires are less burden providing
more steering control the end result is
faster laps he's come into I bust a
little side fun
man's porsche has sold more than 150,000
sport luxury sedan since 2009 even
though they looked a bit overblown from
the rear now the rear is the best part
of a Panamera that's how you turn a
weakness into a strength on this deck
you